(somber music)
- All right, we're
getting close to the end.
There's this lecture,
which is gonna be about culture
very broadly understood.
And then the next lecture,
which is gonna be a kind of review
of the ideas of empire and Europe.
You can think of both of these
lectures as helping you think
through some of the
main issues of the class
as you prepare for the exam.
'Cause I understand that as Yale students,
you would prefer actually
not to be in class,
but to be studying for the
exam, and I'm here to tell you,
you can do both at the same time, right?
Especially the essay questions
in the exam give you a lot
of room to think through
and make arguments, right?
Think through and make arguments.
And so in these last couple of lectures,
we'll mostly be doing interpretation.
So this lecture is about culture.
I'm not gonna try to
define what a culture is.
We've got the whole anthropology
department for that,
but what I have in mind here
is the very broad notion of,
let's say, a set of self,
a set of mutually reinforcing notions
of what a people might be.
So by Ukrainian culture here,
I'm not gonna have time to get into,
with some exceptions,
the details of Ukrainian
literature and Ukrainian poetry.
What I'm mainly concerned
with is the notion of people.
So I'm going all the way
back, if you remember,
all the way back to September
in the first couple of lectures
when I tried to specify
that the modern legal notion
of genocide rests on the
equally modern notion
of a people or a nation,
and that these two things are in a kind
of uncomfortable relationship,
one with the other.
And as we complete this
course during a war,
which certainly has
genocidal aspects to it,
it's worth thinking
about that relationship.
So the Genocide Convention in 1948 assumes
that there is such a
thing as a people, right?
It assumes that there is a society
which has a top and a
bottom, which has some way,
which has some kind of a border
where people are in or people are out.
So the convention
acknowledges of people in law
by presuming that they exist.
You can think of the act of genocide
as a different kind of
acknowledgement, right?
You don't destroy something
if it doesn't exist.
You don't seek to destroy
something if it doesn't exist.
But the slightly tricky part
about this is that very often,
the act of destroying to people begins
with the explicit verbal
negation of its existence, right?
And so, one of the larger
points I want to try to make
in this lecture, maybe the large point,
is that Ukrainian culture,
the notion of what Ukraine is,
where it begins and where it stops,
can't really be done outside
of this larger notion
of an encounter.
It can't really be done
outside of the notion
of an encounter with the Russian Empire,
with the Soviet Union
and contemporary Russia.
Now, as I try to make this argument,
I wanna be clear about
something very specific
about this encounter,
something which makes it
a little bit different
from the other encounters we've
talked about in this class,
which is that this is an encounter
which denies that it is taking place.
Okay.
This is, like, I'm sure you've
all had moments like that
in your lives, right?
Perhaps on a Saturday night,
encounters where, okay,
that was like a really low,
going really low, really fast,
(students laughing)
really early on a really important point.
All right.
But there's a certain
strangeness to an encounter,
or there's this, let me put this,
there's a specific
character to an encounter
where one side denies
then an encounter is
actually taking place.
A third party looking in will say,
"Well, yes, the encounter is happening,"
but there's nevertheless
something specific about this.
So as a way to start,
I want you to just remember that moment
in the third quarter of the 19th century
in the Russian Empire where the existence
of the Ukrainian language is being denied.
It's a very specific thing to do, right?
To go out of your way
to deny something exists
is a very specific form of action.
The Valuev decree of 1863
includes the famous passage
that I'm quoting now, "The
Ukrainian language never existed,
does not exist, and shall
never exist," right?
So, or as we say, in Ukrainian,
Української мови ніколи не було, нема, не буде
Right?
So I don't know. That was kind of a joke.
But there's a very specific,
there's a very specific
thing going on here
when an encounter is being denied, right?
So if it never existed, why
would you refer to it, right?
If it doesn't exist now,
why are you banning it?
But maybe the most
interesting thing is the claim
that it never will exist.
It never will exist.
There's this very specific
kind of omniscience going on
when I make the claim that
something will not happen, right?
I'm denying the basic unpredictability,
or at least, the contingency of everything
which is going to happen
after I issue this decree.
In other words,
this decree is doing a
very specific kind of work.
The relationship between the
emerging Russian imperial
culture and the Ukrainian culture,
which exists at the time, is
taking on a very specific form.
Because of course, it's not
as logically contradictory
or silly as maybe I'm suggesting,
the idea that the Ukrainian culture
or language doesn't exist means
that it's existence can only be described
as part of Russian culture, right?
So it's not that there are no,
it's not that there's nothing there,
it's rather that it can only
be described as existing
as part of something else, right?
And so when I say that you don't exist,
what I'm really doing is that I'm saying
that I do exist, right?
So there's a fancy term for this,
which is like Constitutive Other,
which you're welcome to note down
and use to impress your friends.
But the idea that you
don't exist is how I show
that I do exist.
What you are doing has
no character of its own.
It is a version of what I am doing, right?
And so there's a very specific
thing which is going on here,
whereby Russian culture as it emerges,
is being defined not exactly
against Ukrainian culture,
but somehow riding along on
top of Ukrainian culture.
Anything that seems to be
Ukrainian is actually Russian,
and anyone who denies this
is moved out of history.
So this is where the categorical part
of never will exists comes in.
So this class has been
all about encounters,
a basic argument about the
nation in this class has been
that no nation comes from nowhere, right?
That's why all the founding
stories are so implausible,
like the one with the lady and the snake,
and the one with the guy.
The founding stories are all
really implausible, right?
They're fun, they're silly,
they don't make any sense.
All the stories of ethnogenesis,
including the ones involving the aliens,
they're all implausible, right?
There's always some encounter.
And the whole argument of this class
about how something specific
emerged on the terrain
that's now Ukraine involves,
it involves the Khazars and
the Vikings and the Byzantines
and the Slavs and the
Lithuanians and the Poles.
And of course, it also very
much involves the Russians
and the Soviet Union.
But there's something
very specific going on
from the 19th to 21st centuries
where this encounter has an
ideological quality to it
that the others don't.
Or in the case of the Polish one,
I would say, no longer
have, no longer has,
but in Russia, it clearly does.
So in order to get ourselves to see this
and maybe get ourselves out of it,
we have to kind of look
at some trajectories
in the Russian encounter with Ukraine,
not from the point of view
of how a Russian national
ideology would see them,
but just to note what this
encounter looks like, right?
So this very special thing,
this is the overall special thing.
There have been lots of
European empires, right?
But they all have the feature,
and write this down 'cause it's important,
of starting in Europe except for one.
You see, what's very different
about the Russian Empire
is that it becomes an empire
by going into Europe, right?
By going into Europe.
The Russian Empire becomes
the Russian Empire in 1721,
having moved from Asia into Europe
as a result of the
cataclysm of 1648 onwards.
Remember that,
and then there was that whole
lecture about the 18th century
and the collapse of Poland-Lithuania,
the collapse of the Cossack states,
the collapse of the Crimean Tatar state,
all those things happening
in the 18th century,
leaving Russia in Europe.
But it's not a European empire
that went outwards, right?
It is a state which was
centered at the edge of Europe
in this relatively new city called Moscow,
which first went south and east,
and then its final stage of
development went into Europe.
And the ambivalence of
the relationship with Kyiv
is built into that.
Because on the one hand, on the one hand,
you become European by
claiming Kyiv, right?
'Cause Kyiv has all those European things
that you might want.
It has the old baptism, it
has North European history,
it has the Renaissance,
it has the Baroque,
it has all the European references.
It's just older than you are.
And by a lot, I mean by
five centuries, right?
Kyiv is four or five
centuries old than Moscow.
It is a millennium older
than St. Petersburg, right?
That's a lot.
So the ambiguity is you become
European by going to Kyiv.
But since you are the empire,
you can't acknowledge that the
periphery is better than you.
So this tension is built in
from the very, very beginning.
On the one hand, we are
European because Kyiv,
but on the other hand,
the people who are around
Kyiv have to be the periphery
and are therefore inferior.
That tension is built in from the moment
that Kyiv, Chernihiv,
these places come into the Russian Empire,
and it's still very much
present today, right?
So the Russian Empire vis-a-vis Ukraine
is simultaneously inferior and superior
at the same time, right?
It's superior because
it's big and powerful
and it's the empire,
but it's also inferior
because this is the place
that actually allows us
to become the Europeans, right?
This is the place that allows
us to become the Europeans,
but we can never say that.
That can never be said out loud, right?
So there's this deep tension
which is built in to all of this.
Okay. So one part of this
is the timing, right?
Another part of this has to do
with an encounter in religion.
There probably hasn't been
enough religious history
in this class,
and it's an important element
of the history of Ukraine,
in particular, distinctiveness
between Ukraine and Russia,
not just because there's a
Greek Catholic church in Ukraine
and not in Russia,
not just because church
participation is much higher
in Ukraine than it is in Russia,
but maybe mainly because in Ukraine,
there is not a clear relationship
between church and state the
way that there is in Moscow,
both at present and historically.
For many centuries,
the relationship between
the church and the state,
and including the last 30
years in the lands of Ukraine,
has been rocky and uneven.
The church has been
repressed by the state.
It's been a part from the state,
but it's never been
seamlessly woven together
with the state, and that's
an important difference.
But from the point of view of Moscow,
this curious things happens,
which I mentioned in the
17th century, but it's very,
it's an important example
of this dialectic.
The Russian Orthodox
Church, such as it is,
and now, I'm leaning very
heavily on a dissertation
by the wonderful Yale PhD
graduate, Ievgeniia Sakal,
the Russian Orthodox
Church, such as it is,
takes on its form and its
own narration of what it is
in an encounter with Ukraine.
So if you remember back
to the 18th century
when the Polish-Lithuanian
Commonwealth collapses,
there are all of these educated churchmen
in places like Kyiv and Chernihiv
and they've been having these
debates with each other,
and they've been having debates
with the Catholics and the Protestants.
They've been besieged by
the Counter-Reformation.
They've been dealing with
the Jesuits for decades.
These are very erudite men,
and suddenly, they're confronted
with this new situation
in which there's no longer
the Polish-Lithuanian
Commonwealth to deal with,
no longer the reformation,
Counter-Reformation, all that's gone,
but there are these fellows in Moscow,
and they're suddenly subordinate to them.
So what is the story that you tell?
There's a political story,
I'll return to that,
but there's also a religious
dispute which takes place.
And then this religious dispute,
authorities in Moscow
and authorities in Ukraine
have different ideas.
And the authorities in
Moscow have the power.
The authorities in Ukraine
have the arguments.
But what happens over time,
and this is all verges
on being a general truth,
the people with the power
will eventually figure out the arguments
and they will eventually use them.
So within the space of a generation,
the church authorities in Moscow
are also using the same sources
and the same kinds of arguments
that the church authorities
in Ukraine are using.
In other words, the church
authorities in Moscow,
by way of Ukraine, start reading
the French and the Latin,
and they start borrowing the arguments
from the Western theologians,
and they start disputing
and doing all the things
that the Ukrainians are doing,
and what they come up with
is this interesting claim.
They claim, well, the reason
that we are different,
and we are right about
theological matters,
is that we, the Russian Orthodox Church,
are basically the unbroken,
continuation of the Byzantine church
that nothing has really happened.
It's just all a placid pool of non-events.
"We are pure." Right?
And this is, if you know
anything about Western Orthodoxy,
this is the account to this day, right?
That it's a non, basically a
non-historical institution,
but this argument that they're
a non-historical institution
emerges as a result of historical
encounter with Ukraine,
very much like the political point,
which I made in the lectures
a couple of weeks ago.
The idea that Kyiv and
Moscow are somehow connected,
organically connected,
that Moscow fulfills itself
in Kyiv and vice versa
and all of this,
That is also an argument
which was made by Ukrainian churchmen
in the late 17th century
facing a new position of power,
right?
And you'll remember, it's
a pretty clever argument,
at least in this short term.
If you are in Kyiv,
and suddenly you're being ruled by Moscow,
you make the argument,
"Hey, you and Moscow,
everything actually came from us in Kyiv.
"Therefore, we're very important."
But given a generation or two,
that argument will be
turned around against you,
and it will become something much more
like Kyiv fulfills itself in Moscow.
It all began in Kyiv,
but everything fulfills itself in Moscow.
And so now, the role of Kyiv
is to be subordinate to Moscow.
But the point is that that
whole argument never emerges
without Ukraine, right?
So all of these important
steps in the history
of what's going to become
Russian culture are deeply,
organically connected with Ukraine.
Take a literature, right?
Take a literature.
Okay. Who's the first
important Russian writer
besides Pushkin?
- [Student] Gogol?
- Yes, Gogol.
Who is from?
- [Student] Ukraine.
- As everyone knows, from Ukraine, right?
And his first stories are about Ukraine,
and his family is Ukrainian.
Gogol is the turning point
where the bilinguality
stops being Ukrainian-Polish
and moves towards being
Ukrainian-Russian, right?
From the point of view of
the 20th or the 21st century,
you might think, "Well, the
Ukrainians and the Russians,
they've always been together, blah."
No. It was Ukrainian-Polish
was the normal bilingual
character situation for a long time.
In the 19th century,
Ukrainian-Russians starts
to become the normal one,
and you have these Ukrainians
who write in Russian.
If you don't know Gogol, by the way,
after exams, I know,
but you might wanna start reading
some of his short stories.
If you like the grotesque,
if you have a taste for things
like Edgar Allen Poe or Kafka,
it's truly extraordinary, wonderful stuff.
But the cliche is that we all come out
from under Gogol's overcoat,
which is a play on words
because like an overcoat,
but also, "The overcoat" is
one of Gogol's most important,
one of his funniest and
most important stories.
But Russian literature comes
from this Ukrainian story, right?
So in all of these levels,
we have the same problem.
Another is with educated elites.
So again, by the 20th century,
there are very impressive
Soviet educational institutions.
And by the 19th century,
early 20th century,
Russian imperial ones as well.
But when these two societies merge,
the Kyiv-Mohyla Academy and
Kyiv is far more important
than any educational institution
in the Russian Empire.
And so during the 18th century,
graduates to the Kyiv-Mohyla Academy
are flooding Petersburg, which
is the capital after 1721,
with the educated elites who
help govern the empire, right?
So in all of these ways,
the Ukraine is what's needed
to make a Russian self-assertion,
but that Russian self-assertion
has to negate its own sources, right?
It has to negate its own sources,
or else, it will seem incomplete.
Something related happens
at the level of history
where the Russian story,
as I've just described it,
it has to be a story about
political legitimacy, right?
And again, you can see an
extreme version of this
in Putin today where Russia
exists and has the right to rule
because of baptism in Kyiv in 988.
Nothing that's happened between
then and now really matters.
What you have is an unbroken right to rule
as a result of a kind of
metaphysical event a long time ago.
It's a version of, I mean,
it is actually very much like
and is a version of these
medieval or early modern stories
where a family says,
"By the way, we're descended from wolves,
and not just any wolves, but
the ones who founded Rome,"
or whatever, right?
I'm sort of, that's
kind of a Habsburg joke.
But when families, in
families, you have families,
you may know this.
Families have these kind of,
probably from your family
tells you this story,
like you had this great uncle,
he actually invented the airplane.
If you let families go on like
that, they eventually just,
everybody comes, has descended
from some king or whatever.
I'm making a serious point or trying to,
which is that history
begins with a genealogy
that legitimizes eternal power, right?
So if you're a family,
you have trouble getting at keeping power,
getting power, not so
hard, blood and treasure.
It's keeping power which is hard,
and that requires some kind
of legitimating ideology
and the idea that you're
gonna keep power forever
into the future makes more sense
if you can explain why you've had power
or should have had power
forever into the past,
and so there's some kind of story
about how, what, where
you came from, right?
So a lineage of power,
and that's where political
history comes from, okay.
So now, if you're in the 19th
century and it's Ukraine,
the move that you make is
you counter political history
with social history,
and that's Hrushevsky, right?
That's Mykhailo Hrushevsky.
You then say, "No. History
isn't just about some kind
of legitimating story that
makes sense to the people
who are in power.
It's about actual
continuities in culture."
Right?
That history is about the people, okay.
Then you get into this conversation,
which continues to this
day where if I say,
"History is not about the
power, it's about the people."
Okay. At first glance,
that might seem very
much a matter of justice.
But the obvious question is,
okay, who's the people then?
Are the Jews the people?
Are the Poles the people?
Is everybody who's on
the terrain the people?
Or is it just the people who know,
if history is about the
songs and the stories
and the language,
what about the people
who don't know the songs
and the stories and the language,
but live on the same territory, right?
So this is where there begins in Ukraine,
but not just in Ukraine.
It's just Ukraine's a very interesting
and clear case of this.
And Ukraine begins this, forgive me,
like this dialectic where
neither of these positions is,
it can be exactly right, right?
The idea that history is about
the people is attractive,
right?
But if you push it to an extreme
that makes history just
about the ethnicity
and it becomes ethnic nationalism,
then there's a counter
argument which says,
"No, the people are defined by action.
The nation is a daily plebiscite."
And so it doesn't matter
whether they're Jews or Germans
or Poles or whatever,
it's about participation, and cooperation,
and things like this.
That's the political nation.
But if you push that all
the way to this extreme,
then everything is politics.
Why can't I make compromises
with some other nation?
Maybe I can just take money
from this guy over here.
What's wrong with that? It's
all part of me being political.
And this is the political nation, right?
And so neither these positions
can quite be correct,
at least take into an extreme.
They're in some kind of communication
with one another the entire time,
and that discussion is going on today.
It has to do partly with the Jews,
the Jews in Ukrainian history,
which is an example of culture
which we have to spend
at least a moment on.
The Jews of Ukraine are there
because of currents in Polish history.
The Jews of Ukraine become
Russian imperial subjects
after Ukraine ceases to
become part of Poland.
The Jews of Ukraine,
see over the course of the 19th century,
their traditional way of
life essentially broken down
as a result of the military
draft and other things.
And the Jews of Ukraine,
or some of them in the late
19th century build up a kind
of a modern Yiddish literature.
The most important example of this,
which you will have heard of,
if you come from these traditions
is all of Sholem Aleichem.
Sholem Aleichem is basically,
and now, I'm stealing idea from
my colleague, Amelia Glaser.
but what Sholem Aleichem
is basically doing
is he's taking Gogol and his portraits
to the Ukrainian countryside
and making them gentler,
and bringing the Jews into the
center of the conversation,
whereas Gogol at the
beginning of the 19th century
was very much about taking
mystical pre-enlightenment
beliefs and working them
into modern literature.
What Sholem Aleichem was doing
was taking Yiddish language.
That's important. He's writing Yiddish.
Yiddish language literature and using it.
Yiddish, which is an old language
and only newly a literary language,
taking Yiddish and using it
to write about the problems of modernity.
And what are the problems of modernity?
The problems of modernity are socialism,
romantic love, right.
So the position in Tevye the Dairyman
is that he has these daughters,
and you guys know this,
"Fiddler on the Roof," right?
"Fiddler on the Roof," right.
So it's the problems in modernity
from the point of view of a
Jewish dad, basically, right?
And the girls, all the
daughters all have some,
they all do something unexpected thing,
but each one of the things
they do represents modernity,
like the socialist, the
rejecting the church,
but even romantic love
itself is a modern idea here.
Okay.
So this is, so the Jews are,
if there's going to be a
talk of culture in Ukraine,
the Jews and Jewish history
have to be part of it,
and that includes the broad
destruction of Jewish culture
at the beginning, not of the second,
but the First World War
when the Jews of Western
Russia were deported,
which was one of the
causes of the pogroms,
which happened most intensively
in Ukraine during the war.
We have to also talk about
the assimilation of Jews
in Ukraine to the Russian language before,
but especially after the
Bolshevik Revolution.
And then in Ukraine in particular,
and I'm just very briefly
referring to material
that you've read and we've talked about,
but the mass murder of
most Jews in Ukraine
during the Holocaust.
And then after that, the return of Jew,
not, return is the wrong word,
but the immigration or
the movement of Jews
from elsewhere in the Soviet
Union to what is now Ukraine.
So Ukraine is now one of the
most important Jewish countries
in the world, numerically speaking.
It's one of the few, you
can count them on one hand,
countries that have a Jewish president.
It is the only country in
the world that will ever,
now, I'm gonna make a prediction,
that will ever have a Jewish
president elected by 70%
or more of the vote.
I don't think that's ever gonna happen,
because it won't happen in Israel
because there're always
two candidates, right?
So it's hard to, see, I'm
cheating. I'm using math.
But this Jewish Ukrainian
culture is a post-war,
second, third, fourth
generation Ukrainian culture,
but it's clearly part of
what one could think of
as a political nation, right?
So the greatest, again,
so now, we're in a situation
where the greatest Ukrainian
warlord in history is a Jew,
which proves that God is Jewish
and has a sense of humor.
(students laughing)
In the Soviet Union, there's a version,
and we've talked about this,
of how Ukraine becomes
the Constitutive Other.
The Soviet Union needs
things from Ukraine.
The Soviet Union needs for
Ukraine to be a nation,
but then not to be a nation, right?
So it needs for Ukraine.
So, Ukraine, Stalin, Lenin,
they know that Ukraine is a nation.
They need Ukraine.
They want as much of Europe as they can,
but they have to settle for Ukraine.
They need Ukraine to be a nation,
but they also need it not to be a threat,
and so that's the dialectic
of the 1920s and 1930s
where the Ukrainian nation,
Ukrainian literature,
Ukrainian people are educated.
Literature is supported for a while,
and then it breaks in the early 1930s.
In a similar way,
the Ukrainian economy has
to exist and not exist.
The Soviet Union needs the
Ukrainian economy because of,
and this is a theme which
literally goes back,
I mean, a lot of things, people say,
"Go back to the ancient Greeks,"
but mostly, we're just having fun.
In this case, it really goes
back to the ancient Greeks.
Ukraine is a bread basket, right?
Athens depends on grain
from what is now Ukraine,
just as the Soviet Union
depended upon grain
from what is now Ukraine.
It's a bread basket.
So they need the economy,
but they don't want it to
be the Ukrainian economy.
It has to be part of a
larger project, right?
If they had let the Ukrainian
peasants just grow the grain,
they would've had bigger yields
than they did under
collected by as agriculture.
But collective by as agriculture meant
that it was all under control,
and it would be the Soviet Union,
which would be in charge
of the distribution
and the exports, right?
So the Ukrainian economy has to exist
and has to not exist,
which is a very brief way
of referring to something
that we have talked about before,
which is the death of
about 4 million inhabitants
of Soviet Ukraine during the 1930s.
Something similar can be
said about Ukrainian culture
after the Second World War.
And again, now I'm reviewing a theme.
So we need it, but we don't need it.
And this is, during the Second World War,
we need, we is now the Politburo, right?
We is Stalin.
We need Ukraine because the
war is being fought in Ukraine.
And so, we'll talk up
the Ukrainian nation.
We'll even talk about Bohdan
Khmelnytsky as being a hero
while the war is going on.
When the war is over,
this is all gonna change.
Under Zhdanov, this is
all going to change.
Ukraine is gonna be suspicious.
The Western Soviet Union
is going to be suspicious.
And then Khrushchev is going to find
this brilliant solution.
And I mean, I don't mean that ironically,
and as politically, it
has been very powerful.
If you need the Ukrainian nation,
you need Ukrainian culture,
but you also don't need it.
What do you do?
You say it's real,
but it's reality is
expressed in its merging
with Russia into something bigger, right?
And so the brilliance
of this move in 1954,
you remember 1954, it's when
they gave out the cigarette,
like millions of cigarette packs
with the words, 300 years, on them.
Also, nightgowns, socks too, I think.
The brilliance of that is
that you're acknowledging
that Ukraine is real,
but you're just saying
Ukraine's history went
in a certain direction.
In 1654, Ukrainians made this choice
and it binds on them forever.
It's been done, right?
So let's just remember that.
And the Soviet Union is
a version of this choice,
which was made 300 years ago.
So Ukraine is real.
It's just that Ukraine's
existence is now meaningful
as part of a larger unit with Russia,
and that is the version of
how to think about Ukraine,
which works extremely well
in Soviet Russia and in Soviet Ukraine
for a lot of Soviet Ukrainians
for a very long time.
Something like that, some
version of that from 1954.
And this is an expression,
again, these things aren't just made up.
These things are expressions
of the actual politics
of the actual Soviet Union.
So this might come as a surprise,
but there haven't actually
been that many Russian leaders
of Russia in the narrow
sense of Russia, right?
So if Russia claims the
ancient dynasty from Kyiv,
I mean, they were Scandinavians.
And then the Romanovs,
at least after Catherine,
I mean, the only Romanov we can be sure of
after Catherine was Catherine
because you always know
who the mother is, right?
I really have to stop because
I don't have enough time
to talk about Catherine
the way that I'd like
to talk about Catherine.
But in the case of the
Romanovs, the only Romanov,
I mean, this is dead serious
now about the succession.
The only Romanov you can be sure of
after Catherine is Catherine herself,
and Catherine was a German.
So that's not a Russian
origin story, right?
And then the Bolsheviks,
okay, Lenin is maybe
the most famous Russian
of the 20th century,
but how many Russian
grandparents did he have?
That was like a high level question.
I'm looking at the TAs.
One, one.
Stalin's a Georgian.
Khrushchev is from Russia,
just barely but he grew up in Ukraine.
Brezhnev, as Jenny has taught me,
was born in Ukraine and
had Ukrainian nationality
as his passport nationality,
and changed it to Russian,
changed it to Russia.
So you have to get,
oh, and Gorbachev, half Ukrainian family
from southern Russia,
and I am old enough to remember
people in Moscow making fun
of his accent and saying that,
"He's actually from Ukraine, this guy."
So you have to basically
get to Yeltsin or Putin
before you're talking about Russians
in an unambiguous sense
running Russia, right?
And so the story of how
we need them, right?
We need them, but we
can't say we need them,
actually reflects the
history of the Soviet Union
in all of these ways.
It also reflects that the history
of Soviet industrialization,
where much of what is
important is in Ukraine,
the coal and the steel, and
then later, the rockets.
A lot of what is important is in Ukraine,
and so we need Ukraine.
We need Ukraine.
We need it more than
we say we can need it.
And so that's why what we
need has to be incorporated
into this story about how what
we need doesn't really exist
on its own, exists with us.
And in case I forget to say this,
the point of all of this
is that one can't talk
about Ukrainian culture
without all the encounters,
but this is a specific
kind of encounter, right?
This is a specific kind of encounter.
It's a little tiny bit
like US history where,
with the attitude of whites
towards Blacks where,
"We are us because of you.
You're what makes us different,
but we can't acknowledge you
for that reason, you see."
The different, see, that's like,
it's that same kind of pattern.
The difference is the Europe part, right?
That the Europe part
plays out differently,
but it's that kind of move, right?
It's that kind of move.
So just in case I forget to
say that that's the argument,
that it's an encounter, but
it's not like other encounters.
It's not like other encounters.
But the point of culture is
also, and now, we're gonna get,
now, we're gonna talk a
little bit more in depth
for the next 15 minutes
about the late Soviet period
in the contemporary period.
The the point of culture though,
would be that even
though all these things,
all these contingencies
I'm insisting on are true,
that if you're creating culture,
you're trying just to create,
like you're trying to create, right?
You're trying to create.
And much of the protests that happen
from the sixties onward
are kind of in that spirit
where the notion of
Ukrainian culture is not
that we're trying to defend
Ukrainian national culture,
we're just trying to defend culture.
We're just trying to be ourselves.
And the move that
Ukrainian dissidents make,
especially in the 70s, is they say,
"Look, it's not about Ukrainian culture,
Russian culture writ large.
It's not even really primarily
about Russian culture
and its hegemony,
although that's a problem.
What it's really about is the individual."
This is the move they
make in the 70s, right?
They say human rights
includes the right to be
from the culture that you're from,
and that's something inside
you as a person, right?
And so that has to do,
so that is your normality.
So I'm gonna mention a couple
of crucial examples of this,
and there's only really time for a couple,
but one is 1965 when,
this is early Brezhnev,
Ukrainians are being persecuted,
and at the same time, a film comes out,
which I urge you to see,
called "Shadows of Forgotten Ancestors"
which is by a Georgian
Armenian, Sergei Parajanov,
but it's based on a story
by a Ukrainian writer called Kotsiubynsky,
and it's set in the
extreme West Carpathians,
extreme west of Ukrainian.
It's not only in Ukrainian,
it's in Carpathian dialect of Ukrainian.
It's not socialist realism.
It's magical realism.
And it's quite weird.
It's quite weird and beautiful,
and it's one of the
very best Soviet films,
if that's even the word.
Apropos of this film,
there were protests about
the oppression of Ukrainians.
One of the people who took part
in these protests was a poet
called Vasyl Stus, who
loses his job as a result.
I'm gonna read to you one of his poems
to make this point that
sometimes culture is just trying
to be culture, right?
And that a lot of the defensive culture
in the late Soviet
period was on that basis,
that all these things that
I've been explaining to you,
people understood.
That was there. That was sorted out.
But then, somehow it's all meaningless
unless there's a, there, there, right?
Unless the culture itself is there.
So Stus goes to the Gulag twice.
He ends up dying after
a hunger strike in 1985.
But this is the kind of poetry he wrote.
This one is called "A
Stranger Lives My Life
and Wears My Body."
"It seems to me that it is not I who live,
but another someone lives for me
in the world taking my shape,
no eyes, nor ears, nor
hands, nor feet, nor mouth,
estrange to my own body.
And a chunk of pain and closing myself,
suspended in the abyss.
And you, though born, just burned
and never grew into the body.
You never entered the flesh.
Just a passerby between the worlds,
having sunk to the bottom
of before in existence.
A hundred nights ahead, and
a hundred nights behind,
and between them, a mute doll,
burned white from self-inflicted
pain like a speck of hell.
The laconic cry of the universe,
a tiny ray of the sun trapped
and estranged in the body.
You are awaiting another
birth for yourself,
but death entered into you long ago."
That's my translation from yesterday.
It's much prettier in Ukrainian.
I'm gonna resist the temptation.
It's really nice in Ukrainian.
Мені здається, що живу не я, а інший хтось
живе за мене в світі в моїй подобі.
Ні очей, ні вух,ні рук, ні ніг, ні рота.
It's very nice in Ukrainian.
Learn Ukrainian. Read it in Ukrainian.
So Stus goes, is sent, is imprisoned.
He's released.
By the time he comes out,
there's a human rights movement,
the Ukrainian Helsinki Group,
he defends it and then joins it,
is sent to the Gulag.
Again, he's sent to Perm.
The Gulag in the 70s is much
smaller, but it still exists.
Perm is where I think four members
of the Ukrainian Helsinki Group die.
He is one of them after a hunger strike.
I'm gonna read you
another one of his poems.
We're just gonna do him as a poet today.
This is not my translation.
This is Alan Zhukovski translation,
which was just published a few months ago.
This one is called "The
Lord Has Started Being Born
Within Me."
"The Lord has started
being born within me,
and half-recalled and half-forgotten,
waits till I depart from life.
It looks as if he is outside
me, at the edge of death
where living people
should not dare to enter.
My grandchild and my ancestor, God waits.
Together on my own, that's how we live,
how we exist when nobody is near.
Misfortune thunders like a cannonade.
He is salvation, so, white-lipped, I say,
'Please save me for a second, Lord,
and then, recovered,
I will save myself alone
without assistance.'
But he wants to leave
my borders and desires
to finalize my demolition by salvation,
seeking to force me from myself
amid the gusts of chilling
winds, a saber from its scabbard.
He bides his time and wants to get outside
to make the candle of my pain go out
so that the darkness of obedience
would save me by the touch of Otherness,
another form of life,
another name no longer mine,
along with countless people
inside the kingdom of the frenzied God
who wishes to be born from deep within me,
but I'll preserve that
healing flame for longer,
to not get caught too
early by the darkness.
My pain's black candle
fills my road with light
and represents my stealthy victory."
So culture carries a
shadow with it, right?
Culture stands for itself.
These poems are, they're
not about politics,
but culture stands for itself,
but there's a shadow alongside it.
The shadow from the 1860s
from the Valuev Decree,
the shadow from the 1930s
from famine and terror,
the shadow of the 1970s
of the assimilation
and the forced integration from the top,
which means that when Ukraine emerges
as an independent state in the 1990s,
culture is pursued very, very gently.
There is no strong Ukrainization policy
in the beginning.
Kyiv and Ukraine are
characterized by bilinguality,
by code-switching, by surzhyk,
which is the mixing of the two languages.
The Europe is portrayed in the beginning.
Oh, there's another thing
which is very important
about Ukrainian culture, which is,
especially at the beginning,
oligarchical pluralism,
oligarchical pluralism
by which I mean when you have
several different oligarchs
with several different foundations
and several different TV stations
and several different this and that,
that's a different situation
from when you have one.
It may not be the ideal situation,
but it does mean that
different views emerge
about art and history and other things
with different patrons.
That was very characteristic
of Ukraine in the 1990s, right?
And remain, it's coming
less so, but it's still,
it's a feature, it's a feature of Ukraine.
Okay.
So the early attitude towards Europe,
I mentioned one novel,
which is again, for fun,
Yuri Andrukhovych, "Perversion."
In this novel, Europe figures
as this kind of postmodern,
very distant, beautiful
thing, which we never might,
which we probably never
get to, or if we get to,
it'll be a result of all kinds
of improbable drunken adventures.
That's like the postmodern
carnival version of where we are.
We are this outskirt.
We are this province.
We reach Europe with our
spectacular literature basically.
This changes, I would say,
around the time of the Maidan
about what you've read
a book and had a lecture
where Europe starts to
become much more practical.
where Europe is not,
because the politics of
wanting to join Europe
follows the culture of
wanting to join Europe, right?
And the culture of wanting
to join Europe has to do
with younger people who
see Europe as a future.
And so Europe becomes,
somewhere around the 2010,
it's ceasing to become
a kind of strange thing
which is desired, a
strange object of desire
and more kind of practical
place where we might go.
And a key figure here would be
Serhyi Zhadan, Serhyi Zhadan,
who in Kharkiv, in 2014
had his skull broken for,
this is, I mean, it could not
be more symbolic of the themes
of this lecture, had his skull broken
after he refused to bow down to Russians
in a quite literal sense.
Zhadan is a great novelist
and also a great poet.
He also has a ska band,
which is a rare threefer,
I have to say.
And when he does win the
Nobel Prize for literature,
I want that ska band right
in the middle of what they,
all right.
Okay.
So Zhadan would be an
example of something else,
which is very important,
which is the eastern re-anchoring
of Ukrainian culture,
right?
So I've made this point,
which is slightly awkward
if you're from Ivano-Frankivsk or Lviv
which is that the historical
function of Galicia
was basically 1870s to
1970, 1980s, maybe 1990s.
Right. There was a very
special wolf for Galicia
in that time,
and it remains a kind of repository,
a safe place to go, so to
speak, in Ukrainian culture,
but Zhadan is from a Russian
speaking environment,
and he chooses to write only in Ukrainian
and express himself in Ukrainian
absent emergency situations.
So Zhadan was doing that the entire time.
Zhadan, by the way, is also
someone very much worth reading,
remarkable short stories
if you don't wanna invest
in a whole literature.
Tremendous, what is the title, Jen?
Like the last, "The last," or
is it "The First Gay Club?"
Do you remember?
(student speaking away from mic)
Okay. He has like, among of the things,
he has really good stories about,
he has really good stories about things
which approach being political
without quite being political, right?
So his story about the gay
club is a good example of that.
Anyway, this eastern anchor
point is very important
because some people
were doing it all along,
but then 2014, in Maidan
was a turning point
where major figures in
Ukrainian culture realized
that they weren't really
welcome in Russia anymore
and made a kind of turn.
One of them was someone
called Svyatoslav "Slava" Vakarchuk,
who is the lead singer of Okean Elzy,
which is the biggest rock band.
Traditionally, a very big
following in Belarus and Russia.
After 2014, this became awkward.
Another was the comedian and
writer, Volodymyr Zelenskyy,
who up until 2014, had
a very big following,
a very big career in Russia,
and appears in Russian television
until I think early 2000,
maybe late 2013, early 2014,
but then he realizes
something has changed, right?
So this is a turning
point for a lot of people.
And then in 2022,
we've reached a more
dramatic turning point,
extremely dramatic turning point
and where things are happening
so quickly and so violently
that it's hard to
characterize what's happening,
but a dramatic example of this is,
is the writer, Volodymyr Rafeienko,
who was here at Yale
a couple of weeks ago.
Volodymyr Rafeienko who
wrote only in Russia,
who didn't even know
Ukrainian, which is unusual,
and who ceased communicating
in Russian entirely
with this war and is now a
Ukrainian language writer,
which is not an easy thing to
do, not an easy thing to do.
It's kind of a remarkable
thing for him to be doing.
He said something very
interesting when he was at Yale.
He said, "We don't choose
language. Language chooses us."
And it's a strange kind of freedom,
which like, there's profundity,
there's profundity in that.
What's that?
- [Student] You don't master language.
- Yeah, you don't, right.
Yeah. "You don't master
language, language masters you."
Right. "You don't master
Yeah.
Не ти володієш мовою, мова оволодіває тобою
So another example of this
would be another writer
who was just at Yale, Stanislav Aseyev,
also from an entirely
Russian speaking background,
a writer now in Ukrainian,
and a Ukrainian writer
whose most recent book is about torture,
and it's actually one of the
best bits of prison writing
that's been produced,
I think in Eastern Europe
or maybe anywhere else.
So the final point that I
wanna make about culture
is that we're looking,
okay, two more points, indulge me.
We're looking at a new centrality of Kyiv,
a Kyiv is something
that hasn't been before.
It's a Kyiv which is asserting
itself as a European capital,
and that is something new.
Kyiv has been many things
but a European capital among
other European capitals
in a modern sense is new,
and a proud Kyiv is something new.
And I'm gonna read a poem from Stus,
which is about Soviet Kyiv,
and you'll see why I'm doing this.
It's "Thousand Year Old Kyiv,"
and this is from,
translated by Bohdan
Tokarskyi and Uilleam Blacker.
"One-thousand-year-old Kyiv,
fancied, feeling young again.
Suddenly, Kyiv was aware of hotels,
trolleybuses, trams and
trains, the Paton Bridge,
the ungainly buildings on Khreshchatyk.
Kyiv licked the rough asphalt
with its pagan tongue,
the slopes of the Green Theatre
became overrun by martens,
squirrels, aurochs,
and the god Yarylo's
roaring heathen laughter
drove the Dnipro's waves.
Kyiv coughed asthmatically.
Through the metro's drafts,
the electric trains fearfully rattled,
as a dozen layers of ground,
white from human bones, horses' skulls,
and gray ash of funeral pyres,
rippled like the skull
of an angry bull's neck.
Kyiv strained but then gave up,
just how the devil to
lift this whole assemblage
of new-builds, avenues, motorways,
and the stately birthless
bellies of the inhabitants?
May sacred forces strike you down,
heathen Kyiv hurled a curse.
But then it saw a pack of pioneers,
and, ashamed, it bowed its head.
It hid itself away without a peep."
Pioneers, you have to know.
Pioneers means communist
youth group, right?
So Kyiv finally submits.
That Kyiv of is now gone, right?
The people who are now in charge
of the government in Kyiv,
the people are now in
charge of culture in Kyiv
are of a different generation
that isn't just
post-Soviet or anti-soviet,
it's just something else.
And the very last point that
I wanted to make is that,
although it's too soon to evaluate
what this war means for culture,
one of the very striking things
about this war is the
production of culture within it.
So other people have noted
that this is the most
recorded war of all time,
which is true.
I would note that that act of recording
by a journalist is also an act of culture,
which requires corporeal
risk-taking as well as intellect,
but just the culture itself is going on.
Not to sound too romantic
or pathetic about it,
but right down to and including
in the trenches, right?
I have colleagues who are
still giving their lectures
from where they are right in the trenches,
and the production of poetry
and other forms of culture goes on.
So I'm just going to
read you one more poem.
Please indulge me.
This is from Yuliya Musakovska,
who's a mom who works in IT.
She wrote this in late March,
2022 for her collection,
which is published under the title "Iron."
Her poem goes like this, this is March.
"Such problematic, such frightful poems,
full of anger, so politically incorrect.
No beauty in these poems,
no aesthetic at all.
The metaphors withered and fell to pieces
before they could bloom.
The metaphors buried in
children's playgrounds
under hastily raised crosses,
dead in unnatural poses
by the gates of houses covered in dust.
They prepared meals over an open fire.
They did try to survive.
It was a dehydration that they
perished under the rubble.
Shot in a car under a white
flag made from a sheet
with colorful backpacks
over their shoulder.
They lie on the asphalt face
down next to the cats and dogs.
I'm sorry to say so,
but such verses are all
we have for you today.
Dear ladies and gentlemen,
spectators of the theater of war.
(somber music)